you would think having lots of children
would keep you kind of young tech-savvy
you know you've know what's going on but
david tennant this has not happened for
you you recently found out that you got
left behind you know the world of
texting and things well yeah i wish i
know when you start jobs there's a
because of the meter movement and the
lots of food you know great
straightforward of being made in making
sure what places are safe enough
so now different companies have
different ways of coping with that and i
was i had to for a sure i was doing had
to sit watch a video and prove that i'd
watch this video from start to finish
and it very takes you through things
that are acceptable and not acceptable
in the workplace and then right at the
end of this sequence it's talking about
how to communicate on your mobile phone
and what's appropriate more isn't
appropriate it says and remember the
eggplant emoji is not just an eggplant
[Laughter]
it's but that's not what they mean
there's a whole and it turns out that i
didn't you nothing about this there's a
whole kind of language yes there is
usually based around foot stuffs they
represent other things asking someone
for a taco could easily be
misinterpreted
did you know that the eggplant kind of
looks like it doesn't even look like an
eggplant that's you know and then you've
got the peach if you start adding to
that the raindrops and filled Kylie do
you text do you have a smartphone I do
yes okay then I have no idea how that
passed you by
that's because I thought the emojis were
just meant to represent what they
represented I did knows of this whole
kind of other language you had to learn
can you get explicit imagine what we
need yes needs to move forward and just
call a vagina a vagina
[Applause]
there's a an image of you as the doctor
aha that the fans are not letting go and
it's just this it's a very simple thing
it's just you in the streets right now
doing that now this meme is called David
Tennant in places he shouldn't be right
so you must have seen me I've seen a
couple of things yeah if you don't know
what a eggplant emoji is something the
chance to think of me now obviously
you're beginners a beginner one is just
of course you're at the Royal Wedding
[Applause]
then we've got you in education you know
the answer no one else does you're on it
next Oh
ice-skating
I have then we bought you in film there
you are
and finally hey there you are two
grocery
[Applause]
[Music]